So let's go through some of the negative consequences of not having
local journalism and you just cited a few.
So I just want them to think about this.
Like some people listening to this right now are like, okay,
my local paper is gone. No one's covering high school sports,
cry me a river who really cares. Uh, you know,
I can get everything I need on Facebook, the internet, blah, blah, blah.
You know, like the.
Or like I have too much news to read, like, what are you saying? Like,
I'm so overwhelmed with the news. I want less news.
Not more news is I think like a reasonable position that people take too.
Yeah. So, so that's what a lot of people are thinking.
So here's what we're going to tell them. Elizabeth,
why should they care about not having a local paper in
1300 plus communities around the country right now?
Yeah, 2000 newspapers closed since 2004. Um, we should,
we should care because first of all, our government,
our local government is going to be more corrupt in the absence of local news.
Like whether you're reading it or not somebody who being the watchdog, um,
makes a big difference period.
I can share an anecdote and you probably have dozens of,
but a colleague who is a city Councilman told me that they ran city council
meetings and a reporter showed up and then the newspaper ran out of money
and the reporter no longer was there. And he said,
all of a sudden things became very different and not good,
different, uh, sort of sloppy and unprofessional and, uh,
kind of corrupt different. Um, so th that's a government.
Corrupt is not really the bar we're going for for American government.
Uh, so number one, worst local government, uh,
number two.
Okay.
More polarized partisanship in our country where we're,
um, subscribing to this like national religious, uh,
approach to having our politics,
which is basically tearing us apart from our community.
So there's studies that show the absence of local news increases
polarization and decreases people who vote across party lines.
And this makes intuitive sense to everyone because if you don't get any local
news, then you're just going to be tuning into Fox or MSNBC or wherever.
And then I, you just vote along party lines and that's it. Uh,
and th there's nothing really to, um,
balanced that or adulterated in any way. Uh, so one more corruption,
two more polarization, which is not exactly what we need right now, America,
we don't need any more polarization. This is not a good, good thing. Uh,
number three.
Number three is, um, the, the more local news we have,
the more civic engagement we have and that's like,
that's critical. I mean, we're, you know, we're entering a period,
we're through a period.
That's going to have generational consequences for the could be look really
dark, or I hope look like communities coming together,
rolling up their sleeves and finding real solutions to the nightmare that we're
living in that bring people together. And you know, more people vote,
more people run for office. More people participate in school board, um,
activities when there's local news. And when you don't know about it,
how the hell are you going to participate in it?
Yes. Uh, people run for office last, they vote less.
They don't know what's going on. I got to say,
it's harder to care about something.
If you feel like other people aren't going to care or see it either.
You know what I mean? Like, like if you see it in the town paper,
then all of a sudden you're like, Ooh, uh, school, board elections, Ooh,
city council elections or whatever it is. Um, but,
but if it's just happening in the dark, then you're like, ah,
I must not be important. Uh we're, we're pretty simple. That way.
That's so true. Like the tribal is the tribe thing.
Like we have at our school board debates that we,
we hold that it wouldn't exist if we didn't hold them, that Chalkbeat holds, um,
you know, like it's a cool event. It's like a place to be.
It's a thing to do with your evening. That's really fun.
And hundreds and hundreds of people come and we get students to co
moderate them. I mean, you can make civic engagement fun.
And I feel like we've never had a better opportunity to do that than we have
right now in our country.
Like every single person is asking these questions of themselves. I think like,
what is my police department all about? You know.
What I want people to reflect on right now is that the national climate is
obviously very dark and bleak. Um, but then one counter argument,
because Americans are programmed for counter-arguments at this point,
it would be like, Oh, um, it's okay. Cause communities will step up.
Things will be better in like your town, you know, like,
so what of DC doesn't have its act together? Like, you know,
that the city council will, uh, pay attention to the most important things. Um,
it's a very hard argument to make. If you don't have any local news,
you don't have anyone actually covering what's going on in city government.
There are numbers that show that the corruption argument actually has real
monetary costs where the cost of municipal bonds goes up.
If you don't have local news, because then they're just like, ah, whatever,
let's just like pay whatever bond rate. Um, maybe the,
the they'll take a little bit of backscratching.
It's been like a boom time for researchers who care about local news and
democracy because there's so many natural experiments unfolding over the last 15
years,
given that some communities have managed to hold on to some semblance of
people showing up to municipal meetings and school board meetings and city
council meetings, and some just have zero, zero people.
And so those kinds of studies are like amazing.
And they wouldn't have been.
America, the new land of natural experiments.
It could be our new billing. Let's just see what happens if you have none of it.
Um, so, so Chalkbeat, um, so cool,
uh, helping fill the gap for local education, uh, reporting, uh,
and then the American journalism project tries to take it another step,
which you co-founded a little bit later, uh,
and that's championing nonprofit, local journalism,
business models in communities around the country.
Yeah, exactly. Um, so, uh, we, you know, I,
I I've seen the way that this movie could play out if we're lucky.
Like we, when we, when you say, okay, what's the, what's the math here?
How much money do we need to spend that we're not currently spending to do
we need, um,
it's it's between one and $3 billion a year. Um, and it's.
Very low Elizabeth. I don't believe your estimate. It's too low.
No, you should believe my estimate. Um, Oh my gosh,
you should believe my estimate. It's, it's,
it's low enough that we can do it first of all, but it's, it's grounded in, um,
good thinking. Like we, we don't need to recreate restaurant coverage locally.
We don't need to recreate classified ads.
We don't need to recreate the weather report,
but there's a core civic function that for decades, um,
there's been like a tiny little group of very well-meaning and public policy
analysts are saying, okay,
what are the critical information needs that do exist?
And how can we size them?
It's a fascinating convo. So I guess we're shifting in this direction,
which is great, cause this is what we're where my head's been anyway. Uh,
so if you look at the lost revenue among all
newspapers, uh, it's in the $20 billion range,
uh,
now you certainly don't need 20 billion to replace all this because of what you
just said. Like you're not trying to recreate newspaper circa
1988 or something like read that horoscope. Uh, uh,
so, so, so it's clearly a much lower than 20 billion,
but one to 3 billion seems so reasonable. Uh, you know, I feel like,
and you're demonstrating how it can be done because you're serving a number of
communities. Uh, it sounds like very efficiently. Um,
so the American journalism project has been trying to fill that one to
$3 billion gap.
Exactly. So, okay. How do we feel it? Um, and as you say,
it's a reasonable number.
That's the size of many kind of public sectors that already exist.
Like dance is as a nearly $1 billion sector, public broadcasting,
a billion dollar sector that it's, it's a small amount of money, um,
really in the scope of things. And we have more than enough Atlanta.
It's a very, very small price to pay for functioning democracy and
continued civilization. Yes.
Um, yes, I think so too. And, and I,
so like how do you pay it the fastest way possible is the question that has been
keeping me up at night and when Trump was elected,
I like so many people was really called to say, okay,
what I'm concerned about our democracy in a way that I wasn't concerned a year
ago and what am I going to do about that? And I thought about it and said,
okay,
I need to activate philanthropy in a bigger way than I've done so far.
What does that look like? I mean, and it's pretty simple.
I think it looks like activating great leaders to build new
institutions of the future and activating philanthropy to support them to do it
as at least the first mover. Um, it doesn't have to be only philanthropy.
And, and yes,
I know it's not the best situation that we don't just have like free,
independent money growing on trees that allows people to be totally pure because
that doesn't exist. We ha philanthropy is not perfect,
but it's the best we've got. And so we've got to, we've got to assemble it.
We've got to deploy it to really smart causes. And so that's where, um,
the idea for the American journalism project came from we,
we are on a path to we're close to raising $50 million. Um, and then,
and we've been giving it away as our first fund, um,
to promising social entrepreneurs in the local news space and, and,
you know, organizations like Chalkbeat that CA that are positioned to scale.
Quickly. Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation.
If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notification so we can let you know every time we have a new
episode.